[Applause]
hi I'm Zack white cooler for Rico TV we
are coming to you live from reasons Los
Angeles headquarters on 4/20 and we're
here to talk about marijuana
legalization with four experts on policy
law enforcement industry and science the
science of marijuana thank you for being
here panel appreciate it thank you
answer joining us today are Lynn Lyman
she is the California State Director for
the drug policy Alliance Dianne
Goldstein from LEEP the law enforcement
action partnership kenny morrison the
president of the California cannabis
Manufacturers Association and also a
marijuana entrepreneur manufacturer for
BCC and Jeffrey Chen from the UCLA
Medical School he is a cannabis
researcher and we panel we had a
interesting election we we have a new
president a new Attorney General who
will be talking about a little bit later
but we also saw four states legalized
including California commercial
marijuana three more medical marijuana
and that brings the total up to twenty
eight states plus the District of
Columbia that have in one form or
another legalized marijuana which you
know half more than half the country
that's pretty amazing and there's just a
poll today actually from CBS that found
that 61% of Americans now favor
recreational marijuana legalization
that's that's all-out legalization when
you get into you know questions of
medical and should we leave it to the
states the numbers are even higher so
with that stage set how are you feeling
about the the prospect of marijuana
legalization in our current political
moment and we'll start with you
all right thanks that great to be here
with you again I'm feeling pretty
anxious and assumption so Chronicle
called it I was the bummer ten
but you know today and there in their
paper but you know there's so much
uncertainty and we've really we we have
so much to do just within the state to
implement prop 64 there are many forces
trying to undo just about every piece of
prop 64 so just defending it within our
state is a battle and then of course
under prop 64 there's a lot of local
control so we have 480 cities who are
trying to you know ban it or you know
otherwise make it nearly impossible and
then of course the biggest threat is
from the federal government with
attorney general Jeff Sessions who you
know is way back reefer madness type and
and he's going to he's going to be
coming for California and so we have a
bill friendly bill 1578 to prevent any
local resources local law enforcement
working with the federal government to
interfere with any marijuana activity
that's legal under California law so it
won't stop everything because the feds
can still come in on their own and shut
people down and you know a seized assets
and whatnot but for the most part they
can't do that much without the locals so
if that bill passes then we'll have a
little more protection so it's fair to
say you're in a kind of cautious
vigilance type mindset right now yeah by
the way if you're watching on Facebook
we will be taking questions so leave
those in the comments section Diane
what's your read of the current
political situation in terms of
marijuana legalization you know it's
there's several things and I think I
have some significant concerns coming
from the law enforcement angle is I
spent a career in law enforcement I ran
Narcotics Unit I read I retired as a
lieutenant commander and I think one of
the things that is the most telling is
in this issue of like for example a bee
1578 is the significant pushback from
law enforcement agencies like the
California police chiefs and narcotics
officers the California sheriffs
Association that quite frankly is very
hypocritical so the California sheriffs
Association has taken a very strong
stance and the sheriff of Kern County
Youngblood has basically all
ready said many mischaracterizations and
falsehoods about the bill and so in one
article that I read he said that this
bill would not allow law enforcement to
work with the federal government and
that's completely false and accurate and
so for me my role in my organization is
I do a lot of push back against the
proper role of governance in this issue
and I just find it disingenuous that
sheriff Youngblood on one hand publicly
chastised governor lieutenant governor
Newsom over his gun control measure and
I'm not wanting to talk about guns and
marijuana and the Second Amendment so
his attack was that this ballot
initiative basically was an attack on
the Second Amendment but then he
blatantly
ignores the rule law on the Tenth
Amendment in that the states have every
right to design our own drug policy and
the federal government by SCOTUS rulings
can't compel states to enforce federal
law so what this bill would do is
basically protect the states rights and
our ability to not use our resources
like Lynn said to help the federal
government because everybody has to
understand the only way the federal
government can crack down on a state
compliant industry is with the help of
local and state law enforcement federal
government does not have the resources
to attack every state every city every
region and so we have to do everything
that we possibly can to put up a barrier
to disincentivize our local law
enforcement from working with them now
that doesn't mean that there aren't
places we should be working with them so
illicit grows in our state national
parks we can continue from a law
enforcement perspective to work with the
federal government to remove cartel
growth or if you have have licensed
operators that are actually diverting
out of state it doesn't stop us from
cooperating when there's violations
significant violations of law that are
criminal
nature and are you optimistic that we
will begin to see some of that
cooperation or is it pretty pretty bleak
under the current you know it depends I
think we have a lot of innovative law
enforcement agents law enforcement
leaders that are starting to come out
not necessarily agencies and it's a
case-by-case basis you know is you have
cities like Oakland or San Francisco or
Richmond or West Hollywood even in Los
Angeles County Sherriff's has left a
properly insensibly regulated market
alone because their experience shows
that it doesn't increase crime that in
fact that that it helps neighborhoods
where dispensaries are at and so I think
we just need to continue to push back on
the fallacies and the falsehoods that's
perpetuated by prohibition and Kenny as
an entrepreneur what is your read of the
current political situation are you
optimistic that the industry is going to
kind of power through this or are there
severe roadblocks along the way I think
the overarching you know broader arc
here is one of optimism but like Lin
stated there's reason to be cautious and
anxiety in the short term and there's
still a lot that needs to be worked out
in those smaller kind of story arcs I'm
real grateful for the work people like
Lin and Diane have done making sure Prop
64 passed and I think we're lucky that
the social justice components of that
law went into effect the day it was it
was voted into existence me as someone
in the industry I still think the social
justice stuff almost Trump's my own you
know concerns me in the industry we're
still at a point now where some of the
regulations in the fine print still is
being sorted out and the fact that prop
64 largely dictates the non-medical side
of things rather than MC RSA which was
voted
by the legislature last year which
oversees kind of the rules and
regulations for the medical side of
things we're at a state now we're at a
point now where those two different
frameworks need to be harmonized into a
unitary system so you have a lot of
special interests you know bickering and
angling for what aspects of which one
gets turned into one unitary system so
we we don't have two redundant systems
and kind of one of the newest wrinkles
in this whole thing is because of the
rhetoric from the Trump administration
and sessions and so forth
Governor Brown in his trailer bill has
recommended that we have we we disallow
the colocation of licenses so as a
manufacturer or a retailer or as a
cultivator you have to choose if your
facility is going to serve the medical
market or the non-medical market and
that was something that we when we look
at other states that was something from
the beginning we a trap we didn't want
to fall into was having unnecessary
redundancy and so this was kind of the
newest thing that you know some people
didn't see coming was the fact that the
rhetoric we're hearing from the federal
administration is actually forcing us
into potentially exploring the idea of
unnecessary redundancy in in the
marketplace in the system so for those
reasons yeah there's some some reason to
be anxious and definitely some reasons
to be vigilant and keep fighting and
keep working on things with all the
stakeholders Jeffery from a research
standpoint what's your big picture read
of the situation at this moment sure
yeah
so I think in terms of the current
administration rolling back state's
efforts and Trump has made certain
statements that medical use he's okay
with and so on that end at least for
medical patients or states with medical
only laws and not necessarily adult use
are arguably safer on that standpoint in
terms of the research initiatives
nothing too much has changed cannabis is
still a Schedule one drug it's very
difficult to do research with what has
change
are a few things one of which is prop 64
actually creates a new avenue of funding
for cannabis research ten million
dollars a year to public university then
again but this is where the time where
the the National Institute on Drug Abuse
which maintains the monopoly on cannabis
grown for research purposes doesn't fund
therapeutic research because it's not
the mission of their Institute they
research drugs of abuse and so having
this pipeline of ten million dollars a
year from the state of California is
pretty phenomenal and going toward these
research initiatives and what we're also
seeing is unrelated to any state or
federal government we're seeing
foundations and philanthropists actually
stepping forward and donating to
cannabis research so in Australia there
was a historic 34 million dollar gift to
the University of Sydney to create their
medical cannabis research centre and we
also see foundations like the
Alzheimer's Foundation the Lupus
Foundation the Epilepsy Foundation
starting to advocate and and fund
research into the therapeutic potential
of cannabis now going back to at the
federal level the one good thing that
has happened on that end is despite
cannabis still being a Schedule one drug
the DEA has at least announced the end
to the monopoly on cultivation for
research purposes so University of
Mississippi has been the sole
organization in America for the past 50
years allowed to cultivate cannabis for
research purposes and whenever you
having a monopoly consumers suffer
because there's no incentive to be
efficient or do a good job or respond to
the needs of those around you so now the
DEA has announced this theoretical
universities or potentially even current
cannabis growers could technically apply
to be contracted growers for NIDA for
research purposes and this would really
allow for more cannabis tea into the
hands of researchers to do research with
and if you look at over the past year
NIDA has actually increased or sorry the
University of Mississippi their cannabis
pond there they've actually increased
the amount of cannabis grown by twenty
fold because they realized there's about
to be a massive desire from researchers
to look at this and actually just came
from UCLA we had our inaugural cannabis
research symposium at the School of
Medicine and the univer
he's on fire about this because for once
the funding is there they've wanted to
do research just the funding has never
been there and it's so much red tape
that a lot of these researchers are
before they even get started they're
defeated there's no funding and why do I
have to go through all this red tape so
some stuff coming from the state that's
definitely very positive for cannabis
research a few things happening at the
federal level that's good for the
research side and then the private
sector is really risen up to really fund
some of these research endeavors well
while we're on that topic could you just
give us a sense of how difficult is it
to study marijuana at this point like
what what kind of hoops do you have to
go through and and how are these changes
going to make it a that much easier
sure so in 1970 we passed the Controlled
Substances Act here in America under the
Nixon administration of I'm sure you're
all aware and ever since then cannabis
has been listed as a schedule 1 drug
which by definition have high potential
for abuse and no currently accepted
medical use and it's remained in that
category for the last 50 years alongside
drugs like heroin and LSD and in
contrast drugs like cocaine opium and
methamphetamine are scheduled to drugs
so definitiely the federal government
considers them to have less abuse
potential and more medical use than
cannabis which is a Schedule one drug
so with schedule one drugs you have to
get a schedule 1 drug license which
often can take up two years to get that
license once you do have that license
you have to adhere to all of the
stringent requirements of that research
has to be stored in a very specific way
the safe that you use has to be up to a
certain code the handling procedures
have to be a certain way that there has
to be a chain of custody the DEA does
background checks on all of the members
in the study who might come into contact
with the cannabis they have to do site
inspections they have to make sure that
the floor under the safe is strong
enough that nobody can drill through it
for example to rob the contents of the
safe it's a lot of red tape and you're
talking to researchers who are used to
working unencumbered so for to have a
researcher have to do all of this a lot
again a lot of them are defeated before
they even get started and then that's
just getting the schedule 1 drug license
in getting
approval you still have to order the
cannabis from night up and up until a
few up until maybe a year ago they
didn't have any high CBD strains and the
cannabis from NIDA is very different
than any cannabis you might find in
dispensary today it's the THC content is
three to four times lower it's devoid of
pretty much all other cannabinoids up
until recently it was devoid of all of
the cannabinoids and the terpene content
is pretty low virtually none and so the
real question is we're respective you
know researchers go through all this
effort to then study something that
doesn't look like anything like what's
happening in the real world so does it
make a lot of sense at that point for a
lot of these researchers to go through
that and then we talked about obviously
the difficulties with funding and until
recently there are even more layers of
approval you need something called the
Public Health Service review for the
Department of Health and Human Services
a year and a half ago the Obama
administration removed that but that was
just an example of another layer of
approval that would add however many
months to your study and to end this the
the current PTSD study which sue Sisley
in the University of Pennsylvania that
and that was funded by the
multidisciplinary funded by maps that
was a study that took I believe six or
seven years to get off the ground
because of all the regulatory hurdles
when the study was ready to go they went
tonight at the order of cannabis they
didn't have the right ones available and
have any CBD cannabis ready so that's
kind of been where we've been for the
past 50 years so and I want to talk a
little bit more later about you know
what are some of the more promising
areas of research in this field but
first I want to ask you Lynn you know
drug policy Alliance was a very
important player in terms of prop 64
which is the California legalization
initiatives that passed and it's the
largest scale legalization of
recreational marijuana so far so it
matters outside of this state because a
lot of people are going to be looking at
what this this huge market what emerges
in this huge market so in broad strokes
what exactly did prop 64 accomplish
and when can we expect to see a real
aboveboard market emerge so it's a 62
page initiative so there's a lot lot in
there let me try to give you the
highlights that there's the criminal
justice pieces that can you mentioned so
let me just name a few of those we
reduced or eliminated all marijuana
offenses on the books other than selling
cannabis to children and there's there's
a few other things that are really
outside of the scope that remain
felonies everything else has been
reduced to a misdemeanor and infraction
or altogether legalized and it's
applicable retroactively Lee so about
6,000 people still in California jails
for one of these marijuana charges are
now applying for release that went into
effect immediately at midnight on
election night are applying to be
resentenced and released over a million
Californians have a marijuana record and
they can now have that record cleared
pretty much automatically filling out
some paperwork
we have about in the first two months
about 2000 people filed for that
paperwork and the other huge piece of
the decriminalization was that we ended
arrests of children in California for
marijuana offenses a child will never be
arrested again in this state and you may
know that that's the way kids get into
the criminal justice system is through a
marijuana offense so we are hoping that
this puts a big dent in the school to
Prison Pipeline so those are some of the
Primo Justice pieces and those took
effect immediately everything that had
to do with commercial regulation and
licensing doesn't take effect until
January of 2018 and so that the state is
actually required you may have heard
that there's going to be a delay with
licensing but but under California law
the state is required to begin licensing
by January 1st 2018 it doesn't mean
they're going to hand out all the
licenses at that time we expect them to
start smaller and maybe do some
provisional licensing some emergency
licensing but once we begin to license
then we begin to collect the revenue and
that's really the other big part of this
initiative is is the revenue and it's
expected to raise about a billion a year
and that revenue is going to a number of
critical issues in California
right now one of them is environmental
restoration from the illegal marijuana
rosin the public parks another one is
drug treatment we haven't had
sufficiently funded drug treatment in
California for about 20 years since
EPA's initiative in 2000 and then the
other piece is for the first time ever
in addition to the research money and
there is research money specifically for
medical and then more broadly for for
legalization but in addition to that we
put in a first-of-its-kind community
reinvestment fund so 50 million dollars
a year will go back to those communities
that have been the most targeted and hit
hardest by the war on drugs so
communities that have been decimated
with the rest incarceration over the
years and had their families ripped
apart and so those those communities
will be first in line to receive that
money but we would have to begin
licensing so that we can actually
collect the revenue and that's going to
happen in January right and as that
starts to happen Kenny and it's you know
it's going to be this mixture of state
and local authorities implementing this
what do you hope that and as you
mentioned there has to be a kind of
reconciliation between the medical
regime and the recreational regime so
what do you hope that regulators get
right like what's the most important
thing for them to get right and what are
some of the pitfalls you know from a
manufacturer's perspective that they
really hope they avoid I think broadly
the most important thing from my
perspective to get right is I think it's
important for as many people that are
operating in the pre regulatory market
to transition into the regulated market
right if we have people who are
operating today who are looking at
January 2018 as their date of retirement
or their date of going back underground
or staying underground shall I say then
I think there's still more work to do I
think transitioning the existing
industry is kind of top priority right
because we're trying to end the
we're on drugs to some degree here so so
would that involve just not creating too
much bureaucracy and red tape for them
to navigate or just issue as I leaving
enough light finding a sweet spot on
taxation you know making sure that the
the state is willing to license more
people rather than not so many people
and and there's a lot of work to do yeah
can I just yes son I I think what Kenny
saying is so important and it's often
overlooked the California is the only
state that's legalized that had a
twenty-year industry so it's not like
we're starting from you know it's three
or four year industry the way you know
they may have been in Colorado or a
two-year industry as it was Washington
we've been doing this for twenty years
and so we have to transition otherwise
we are telling this huge number of
people who have worked in this industry
when it was unregulated and dangerous
and taking high risks that that they
have to stay underground and we won't be
able to tax the product we won't have
dealt with any of the public safety
issues we won't have safe products for
consumers so all of the intentions
behind regulation will be undermined if
we don't help people transition from a
public safety standpoint I think what
both Ken elands they are really
incredibly important for me the sensible
sweet spot on taxation I think is an
issue in what I liked about 64 it's the
lowest tax rate across all the other
states but the problem is is local
control and so for example you know in
the city of Costa Mesa because I live in
Orange County I just saw an article that
the licensing and regulatory process
that they're proposing for a
manufacturing facility of like one cost
was 27,000 and the other one was over
20,000 and so that's not going to help
public safety that's going to just
encourage the illicit market and so we
need to be able to go back and edge
our City Council people our County Board
of Supervisors that if you over regulate
you're not going to have the effect on
the illicit market that we should and
then the other issue is you know when
you start talking about the differences
between the curse of the medical
marijuana regulations and and prop 64 is
the the police chase and the sheriff's
continue to want to exclude people who
have had felony arrests previously for
cultivation and I think that's also
wrong as well because that will continue
to feed the illicit market and so law
enforcement responses to over-regulate
and that's not going to help Public
Safety it sort of puts the people at a
disadvantage who created the industry
from participating in it right we said
we we created the template we kind of
our business types were the ones that
were validated by the creation of these
license types but then certain people
are saying but you can't hold a license
so you know there's something that needs
to be figured out there oh and do you
get the sense then that the law
enforcement agencies and lobbies are
just going to fight this tooth and nail
to the very end or are people coming
around well I you know I think that the
big issues we have to look at the
history California
you know 1996 we we passed prop 215 and
I was a police officer then and this was
exactly what our law enforcement agency
did is they our city attorney created a
ban and they said we don't care
what the voters want we're going to take
people's cannabis away and we're going
to force them to go to court and we're
going to make them bring their doctors
in order to get cases dismissed and so
they're they aren't quite as obvious at
this point for us over because what the
California police chiefs will tell you
is we support the appropriate regulation
of medical marijuana yet they set up all
these barriers that undermine the
successful implementation of the
emerging industry
and I think what's been very interesting
from my perspective though is we've
actually had more wins than losses in
drug policy in the last six years yes is
that the criminal justice Lobby is
incredibly powerful I wrote an article
during prop 64 and I pulled out just
five of the the law enforcement lobbies
organizations the the narcs the Chiefs
the California super visors and Porac
and one other and they've had in the
last ten years spent close to ten
million dollars on lobbying in paying
lobbyists so that to me is is a use of
indirect and direct taxpayer dollars to
undermine what we the people want to
accomplish and I think a law enforcement
lobbying is unethical and it goes
against the grain of where we've been
placed into the executive branch of our
government where we're supposed to not
make the laws because we are the only
people outside of the military that are
allowed to kill people you don't give us
the power to make the laws we're only
supposed to enforce them great point I
have a there's with a question from
Facebook for Jeffrey I believe it's from
Rachel Brennaman she says from a person
who wavers on the issue of recreational
marijuana what have you found out about
the long-term effects of daily marijuana
usage can cognition and decision-making
abilities be harmed by long-term
marijuana use yeah so this is a question
that's brought up a lot in the
scientific community and the difficulty
in answering this question is that there
certainly in any sort of a study you're
looking at this from an observational
standpoint and it's always hard to tease
apart correlation and causation and the
studies are often conflicting to for
every study that shows that people who
use cannabis for a long period of time
have drops in IQ you might see another
study in a different country looking at
a different population in might say we
don't really see that measurable amount
of IQ so it's really hard
when you're trying to compare these
studies because again they're looking at
different countries just the
methodologies of these studies are very
different and at the end of the day even
when we do see certain studies pointing
towards harm's very hard to tease apart
correlation and causation is it that the
is it that 20 years of cannabis smoking
led to those IQ drops will often
cannabis uses often comorbid with
tobacco use alcohol use and use of other
drugs as well and so it's really hard to
tease apart what's actually causing this
and so there there is currently a large
longitudinal study that's embarking in
the u.s. that's being what's called the
mind study and it's being run out of
Harvard and it's supposed to be a ten
year longitudinal study that is actually
able to kind of measure these sample
points over time and well you know we'll
have data on that study I think that
study is still pretty early on and its
ten-year span so we'll have some results
from there but I guess the takeaway that
I've really gotten from the scientific
community that's certainly a lot of the
harms especially a lot of the harms that
we were led to believe that kids ago are
overblown it's certainly not harm less
but at least that is a lot of the harms
that we might have heard we're growing
up I've certainly been overblown at the
end of the day we just don't know that's
really the yes so a couple things on on
this issue of long term effect first of
all I think that for those of us who use
cannabis every day as I do it hasn't had
any long-term effect and I think I get
smarter every day but but but the other
thing that that we have to really look
at and I hope that the research and I
think it must go there is is the issue
of Tolerance which is distinct with THC
from from every other psychoactive drug
how THC works in the system and so the
more that you use the the more the
effects change and in many ways diminish
particularly the effects that people
might be more worried about like feeling
dizzy or paranoid or whatever it may be
so as you
a daily user those effects really
diminish and so so if these studies have
to not just look at you know this
one-time use but you know people who use
over time and how is that different than
someone who uses once a week or once a
month on the flip side of that question
you know we're talking about harms the
oak another open question is the
possible benefits that medical cannabis
has and this was something that was kind
of laughed off by Jeff Sessions the new
Attorney General he kind of laughed at
the idea that it could be an effective
treatment for chronic pain and possibly
even substitute for opioids so it's a
hot topic right now because there's you
know there's an issue with opioids what
what do you make of that what are some
of the promising areas for medical and
what do you make of the kind of whole
opioid cannabis let me jump in real
quick because literally this week you
know 4/20 is great because you always
get great 4/20 news about a lot of the
really positive things that are going on
there's a couple researchers this last
year that did a study on Medicare costs
associated in medical marijuana state
that were really promising but they
focus mainly on seniors so they just
released a study on Medicaid recipients
who in medical marijuana States and
costs associated with running the
programs and what they saw is in states
with Medicaid that they are seen as well
significant cost savings because there's
been a huge reduction in Medicaid
prescriptions and in fact I brought the
article that anti-nausea drug
prescriptions fell by 17%
antidepressants by 13 prescriptions for
seizure and psychosis drugs also felt
12% and so when you start talking about
for me from a policy perspective is
what's the role of governance is you
know a
a medical marijuana industry can help us
save healthcare costs that are
significant that are less damaging you
know we are now seeing studies relative
to the use of cannabis as an exit drug
for opioids as a substitution that is is
beneficial in to easing our heroin and
our opioid prescription issues so I
think that that there are going to be
benefits and I think that research and
science is going to be the way that
we're going to see those positive
outcomes yeah definitely to add to that
there's there's there was a study that
came out of last year the roll familiar
with showing about a 25% drop and opioid
overdoses and states that had medical
marijuana programs and in clinical
trials and controlled clinical trials
using night of cannabis this was
actually data that was presented our
symposium early today the work of
doctors neva Cooper out of Columbia you
actually see that cannabinoids have an
opioid sparing effect and that is you
need to achieve a similar level of
analgesia which is reduction in pain if
you have let's say you normally needed
10 units of an opioid you might need
only 2 units of the opioid and when you
add cannabinoids and you can actually
create the same level of analgesia and
if the effects aren't additive there's
synergistic so it's not 1 plus 1 equals
2 or 1 plus 1 equals 3 before and so
this opioid sparing property of
cannabinoids is starting to get pretty
well fleshed out in literature and as
you all know there recently there was
the National Academy of Sciences
released kind of a landmark report and
one of the one of their strongest
conclusions was that there was there's
pretty definitive evidence that
cannabinoids and cannabis can be used
for chronic pain and you don't see and
you know you talk about the issue of
tolerance and I know at least you know
with with opioids you also get a really
rapid rise in tolerance you don't end it
but so it's that effect is not as robust
with cannabinoids whereas opioids to
continuously escalate to get the same
pain
the effects which often leads to
overdose or leads to drug seeking
behavior I mentioned sometimes patients
move on to heroin you know in in
Washington the the number one question
that's being reported in the so called
adult use market it's a term that I
struggle with and I'll get into that in
a second is the number to talk to
questions that the budtender is asked is
what will help me with my sleep
what will help me with my pain so to the
woman who said she's kind of on the
fence about whether or not you know
so-called non-medical adult use social
use you know whatever term you want to
put on it how she you know how she feels
about that
I think the terms medical use and
recreational use are both a little be
labored because how would you categorize
the massage how would you categorize
yoga wellness right is it is it medical
or is it recreational it's a different
way of thinking about your well-being or
the boundaries aren't as clear yeah and
the fact we heard for so long that oh
you know medical use that's just a
slippery slope tout and out legalization
well in a state in like Colorado we see
the but both both of those systems you
know both uses really coexisting side by
side very very well and if adult use was
just a if medical use was a slippery
slope to out-and-out legalization
medical use would have disappeared and
it's not if anything when people come
into a so-called non-medical store
asking what will help me with my sleep
what will help me with my pain the adult
use market is actually reinforcing the
notion of cannabis as a therapeutic
wellness model and you know when we talk
about the science that Jeffrey brought
up and that the Diane was talking about
this is these are scientific studies
that are apparently being ignored by the
top law enforcement officer in America
yet Trump himself on the campaign trail
was a little more ambivalent about it he
seemed to be saying
you know medical yeah let's do medical
everything else we'll leave it to the
states you been we have a spokesperson
Sean Spicer kind of saying we're going
to have a crackdown then backing off
that you know when we think back to the
Obama administration he seemed very
friendly to legalization during the
campaign but then had a big crackdown in
the early years so do we have any
prediction in terms of what the Trump
administration is going to do here well
if there's one area that we don't have
to predict because it's already
happening and that is deporting
immigrants for marijuana use and we're
talking about you know permanent
residents green card holders can be
deported just for admitting to use
having a medical card is indicating your
guilt that you have used medical that
you've used cannabis and you can and
will be deported one in six people who
are deported from this country are
deported for marijuana
I mean it's raising so that's already
happening in the Secretary of Homeland
Security I think just yesterday or the
day before John Kelly said oh yes we
will absolutely use marijuana as as a
reason for deportation so that piece is
already happening but I think the what
we're going to see is in it so I'll get
to Trump and sessions in a moment but
the biggest concern we have for places
where we have legalized is the continued
criminalization of people who use in
public because we didn't legalize use in
public because that would have been
impossible we would not have been able
to pass an initiative and so right now
it's only legal to use in a private
space you know here in a business or in
your home and so the people who don't
have private spaces tend to be poor
people and so we are worried and we've
seen it in Colorado huge rises in DC as
well in ticketing people or public
consumption and that is the beginning of
the criminalization of people so that is
also continuing to have
and I think our biggest worry with
sessions I mean Trump again I don't
think he has a big position on this but
I think he's going to let sessions do
what he wants to do in that so we need
to be watching and I have every reason
to believe that sessions will come from
California and crack down particularly
on our recreational markets and so we
are advising the state to give out to
license types regardless of how the
state the system is unified or not that
there always be two licensed types
because Jeff Sessions has said you know
he leave medical alone for now we're
coming after recreational and I do think
that that's going to even with these
overwhelming numbers against that you
still think it's not going to stop
little Jeff Sessions no no not at all
anyone else is mostly no issue Jeff
Sessions is a die-hard
Richard Nixon drug warrior that is not
science-based it's you know he his his
whole ideology is a rhetorical ideology
that we've been dealing with from a law
enforcement law enforcement perspective
you know going back for a long time and
the I think that there is pushback on
him from Republicans in Congress and
Democrats I mean we do there is some
some optimism that we can have I mean we
have a cannabis caucus in Congress okay
so we so we need to continue to not be
apathetic and to make certain that we
operate not just on a local in the state
level with regard to politics but to
make certain that we're calling up our
senators and our Congress people and
holding them accountable and making sure
they understand that we're part of that
70 you know it's 80% that you know
favours medical marijuana 61 that favors
adult consumption and 71 percent that
basically in the CBS poll said leave the
states alone respect the Constitution
understand that we don't want the
federal government intervening
in our industry and so is the the more
they hear from not just policymakers but
from the industry but from you know
doctors from from people who have
personal stories to tell about why it
makes a difference I spend time up in
Sacramento a lot and and staffers and
legislators love that were there but you
know what they want to hear they want to
hear your personal story that if you're
a cancer patient or if your dad has
dementia how that helped or if your
child has epilepsy or if your state
compliant business was rated
inappropriately by the federal
government and your assets were seized
we need to make it personal and hold
them accountable through voting is what
I want to go to some of our facebook
questions that have been coming in so
will Canada is legal is it this is from
Gary cook well Canada's legalization
have any impact on the u.s. federal
policy towards legalization does anyone
know anything about Canada you know I
think it's a it's a very interesting
thing because I think I saw an article
that customs and border recognizes it
and their concern is that they need to
make certain that Canadian citizens
understand that marijuana will not be
legal in the United States and that you
can be prevented from crossing over and
visiting you know it's very interesting
I think one of the things that is going
to be a positive necking for Canada's
you may very well see Canadian tourism
increase you know one of the things
that's happened in this administration
is we're seeing a significant drop in
tourism into the United States right now
simply because people are concerned that
they're going to get turned away at the
border because of the way that we're
investigating people coming into the
United States even if they're just
coming in as turrets right now
there's a question from Howard Pena who
says in highly red states like Texas do
you think decriminalization is needed
before medical will be considered so in
those states where it seems like a long
road to legalization do you see any path
forward for a place like Texas
absolutely and there's a movement going
on in Texas but I don't think you have
to do D chrimbus or you do medical I
think you could do either one first
depending on on where your state is that
and sort of if you have a medical
cannabis community if you have those
patients to tell those stories sometimes
that's really the impetus to pass
medical if you have the the data that
show that mass numbers of people have
been criminalized rested incarcerated
then then you have the push back to get
D crimp so it kind of depends on what's
going on in your state but I don't think
Texas is actually that far behind us on
on this this is a more of a comment from
Allison silvus who says the top law
enforcement officer must go by the laws
not to studies it's up to Congress to
change the laws so any response to that
idea well it is up to Congress to change
the laws but according to the Tenth
Amendment and a number of Supreme Court
decisions going back for quite a
significant period of time
literally state that the federal
government cannot compel state
government local law enforcement which
is part of our state government to in
fact assist or investigate or implement
federal drug laws so it doesn't mean
that we don't allow them into our state
they can do that but why should we use
our own taxpayer dollars to help the
federal government under mine our own
state constitution and our laws and I'm
a real I think that's a real significant
issue relative to the Tenth Amendment
and so yes Congress needs to change it
and there are people in Congress that
are trying to work on that right now and
I mean this this is
kind of an issue that separates the real
Federalists from the fake hypocrite ones
yeah
the bottom line is that we are
ultimately for this tension to resolve
they are going to have to produce
something for federal levels you know
take it off schedule one is there any
hope of that happening anytime soon
inland probably it's more familiar with
it with a bunch of the recently enacted
they're not enacted that that are in
process there's multiple federal bills
right now that have been introduced that
are looking at everything they're from
be scheduling to respect states rights
to Maine and you know every year even
though we've had a Republican Congress
for a while now we've actually increased
our number of votes on those bills every
year and so we're running them again
this year and you know despite who's in
charge in the White House I think we
still have a strong bipartisan walk
within Congress to move this forward I
don't know if we'll get signature on
anything in this administration but I
think that Congress is in as good of a
place to pass this as it was last year
the year before
Theodore Lee asks should states be able
to override the will of voters to
legalize mead by making implementation
conditional upon factors which voters
never envision well if they do that will
take them to court because of a see
legal so yeah I mean prop 64 you know
the great thing about our voter
initiative is that it is the highest law
of the land the not-so-great thing is
it's a really expensive and exhausting
way to make policy we should be able to
make policy through our legislatures but
because of political political realities
and special interests that you know it's
often difficult on complex hot-button
issues and so we have to go to the
ballot but but again the great thing
about that is that that is the supreme
law and so it is you know above anything
that has passed in the legislature so
when the legislature is looking to make
any changes to prop 64 you know they
have to do within the constriction
of what we set out and we did in pops of
support say they could make some changes
specifically around regulation and
that's just a common-sense thing you
know there has never been in the history
of the human race there has never been a
commercial cannabis market besides
California it just hasn't happened so
the few the few commercial cannabis
markets that now exist in the world
which is a lie and a handful of states
here are all less than 5 million people
each so this is the first time that at
any jurisdiction of this size has
attempted to create this market and so
we did leave flexibility for the
legislature to to amend some of those
regulations and I'd like to close out
with this question we'll just go down
the line quickly with look into your
crystal balls and give me your
predictions for what's coming next on a
macro scale with marijuana legalization
or maybe drug legalization more broadly
you know it kind of seems like we're at
a tipping point especially with public
opinion swaying totally in favor of it
more states than not legalizing it in
some sense one sense or another what do
you expect to have the next like more
states coming on board are we going to
even start talking about other drugs
what what do you think is next in this
in this fight can I go last sure yeah a
lot of press there with me well I think
I think certainly the scheduling of
marijuana or the rescheduling marijuana
is pretty eminent you're looking at 90%
of Americans I think it should be legal
for medical purposes they're seeing a
strong call from the scientific
community it's certainly the research of
the cannabis needs to go forward up
unadulterated and I think that will
apply to other drugs that are scheduled
on drugs that we've been trying to
research MDMA and still aside in two
other notable examples so I think
marijuana will pave the way first have
discussion that we should at least be
researching these compounds now because
I know how they can be regulated and how
they can be how the public can have
access to them is a whole different
story but it's very hard to make an
argument now that we shouldn't even be
researching these compounds whether for
the therapeutic effects or to understand
more about the hon so I think that's
really what's imminent is if the read is
the rescheduling of canvas that we
scientists can do work with it
Kenny any thoughts of where the industry
is headed I kind of sort of set all my
answer okay no so if you um you know I
remember a few months ago on CNBC
watching a pot barons of Colorado or you
know some much animation alized show
about people making a lot of money in
Colorado
maybe with CNN but it was immediately
followed up with something about you
know the therapeutic use of psychedelics
and so I think what we're seeing is
we're starting to see people being more
tolerant and open to the fact of using
psychedelics medicinally interesting so
just like alcohol prohibition was ended
on a state-by-state basis I think what's
critically important my organization
cannabis is just a small part of what we
do we do total criminal justice reform
and look at every single drug on that
schedule one I can make a case for every
single drug on that schedule one to have
medicinal values it was adequately
research I mean if you look outside our
country you have heroin assisted
treatment programs in Switzerland and in
other places and in particular from a
public safety standpoint is in
Switzerland they reduce property crime
almost by eighty percent when they
initiated a heroin assisted treatment
program based on a public health
strategy so I think we're we're headed
down the road in the Reid innovation of
public safety and taking it away from
law enforcement ad or criminal justice
system as being the only people that are
allowed to dictate it and creating a new
definition which means that it's
community health and safety and that law
enforcement goes back to its role of
dealing with to criminals and crime
prevention and it's not just arresting
people we need to develop law
enforcement into a holistic one piece of
the puzzle that it that doesn't take
away from mental health programs or
public health treatment or
education or every place else where we
do right now so I think that within ten
years we will see the outright end of
marijuana prohibition I think it's going
to take us about ten years to get there
for drug policy Alliance and like Italy
we do a lot we work on a lot of other
issues outside of cannabis our next big
campaign which we'll be unveiling in the
next couple of weeks is all drug
decriminalization and so this is a model
that has been pioneered in Portugal with
incredible results I mean everything
goes the right way you know youth uses
down and treatment is up and you know
all of the health indicators are up and
so really everything you would want to
see and so we will be launching what we
expect to be another you know 10 to 20
year campaign in this country to
decriminalize all drug use we believe
that absent harm to others nobody should
ever be punished for what they put into
their bodies and that's and that's why
we need all drugs you Chris well I'd
like to thank my panel for joining us
today and everyone in our live audience
and our online audience thanks for
watching happy 4/20 everyone
[Applause]